ils attendent depuis plusieurs semaines
un ralentissement de la propagation mais
les sud américains vont devoir encore
patienter
depuis le début de la pandémie ce sont
plus de 5 millions de cas qui ont été
recensés pour deux cent mille morts
c'est au brésil que le virus fait le
plus de ravages avec 95 mais décès
comptabilisés ce qui fait de lui le
deuxième pays le plus frappé par le
commis de 19 dans le monde derrière les
etats unis
des chiffres qui terrifie la population
c'est lamentable
surtout quand on a un président qui en
rit donc ça me fait peur et c'est
tragique n'est ce pas et nous voyons que
les choses reviennent à la normale mais
je pense que la normale n'existe pas je
pense que nous avons sont trop vite
tous souffrent trop vite et je pense que
tout le monde va être infectées et que
le nombre va augmenter en argentine la
crise sanitaire est venue s'ajouter à
une crise économique majeure et les
quatre mois de confinement n'ont pas
arrangé les choses
la capitale buenos aires est connaît
actuellement une explosion du nombre de
chômeurs dimanche la barre des 200 mille
cas de contamination a été franchie en
argentine conséquence les réunions sont
désormais interdites dans tout le pays